okay good evening ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to tonight's planning
committee meeting my name is councilor
Peter Richards and I will be chairing
the meeting this evening
um some housekeepers are made to start
with we're not expecting a fire alarm so
if one does go off if you would kindly
follow us to the car park over the road
next to the pub
um we will need to check your names off
against the entry list to make sure
you're out the building safely before we
send you on your merry little way uh
mobile phones if you could please turn
them off or at the very least are silent
I appreciate sometimes there are
emergencies So Silent at them as a
minimum off would be preferable
um as long as they don't disturb the
flow of the meeting I am perfectly happy
the meeting itself is a meeting in
public it is not a public meeting so
only the people registered speak will be
permitted to do so at the appropriate
time we'll call you forward to one of
the many microphones in front of you if
you press the button on the right it
will turn red you should be able to see
a light here and you will be live and
active I will give you your time at that
point and of course we will give you a
warning before your time is up and my
button doesn't work so I will just give
you a verbal 30 for the time is up let
me introduce everyone at this table if I
may say to my far right we have Kira
Keller who is our Community Services
representative to my immediate right we
have Sue Mullins who is our solicitor
and our planners in no particular order
are Charlotte dicks Joe Brook and
Malvina it's yak and our planning
manager this evening is Dale Barker to
my immediate left Dale I believe you've
got a statement to make thank you chair
my role this evening is to provide
impartial advice and to assist members
in their decision taking thank you chair
fabulous thank you very much Dale um we
have apologies for absence please yes we
have apologies from absence from
counselors Adam
thank you very much members do we have
any disclosures of Interest please
councilor Parry first
thank you and good evening chair I would
like to disclose an interest in
connection with planning application 22
forward slash zero three five three
zeros forward slash ful
um I have met the applicant a couple of
times I've been out on a litter pick and
invited him to a counselor meet the
counselor's surgery because
um he is a Conservative candidate for
wellsporn East and Rural I therefore
think it is most sensible that if I sit
down from the committee
um on this particular application whilst
I have not discussed the planning
application with him I think in the
situation with the elections next week
it is much better to stand down from the
committee for this application thank you
chair
understood thank you very much cancer
Kendall uh exactly what my colleague
just said about Council Howard just said
in terms of item six that's a reference
2203530 ful I also am the ward member
for item five which is uh application
reference two two zero zero one eight
two slash out I registered to speak on
that so I also stepped down from the
committee thank you understood thank you
very much cancer Crump
okay Mr chairman up here again
application
22-03530 slash ful Old Mill House I've
worked closely with my other roles uh
with the applicant so for many years I
will be standing down on that I
understood thank you very much Council
Foreman
uh thank you chair on item 22 03530
I received an email
from which I'm sure everyone else has
received thank you very much I was going
to say the same I'm assuming of a nice
house so we've had an email from
actually with the uh registered one of
the registered speakers
um I'm assuming everyone has received
the same thing I'm seeing not from
iPhone so we'll have a blanket one for
that
um while we're on this item so to me
again 2203530 ful that's Old Mill House
in Clinton
um as you've heard uh the applicant is a
conservative uh candidate
um personally I've never met him I don't
know who he is uh and I'm here with open
mind so I will remain on the committee
um I have spoken to both our solicitor
and our monitoring officer about that
and they are comfortable uh with my
position
um does anyone else have any disclosures
to make counselor Harvey on the basis
are you just on the basis you just said
what you have uh chairman uh I'm a
conservative Council in the next
election I I don't know this applicant
at all I come with an open mind I'm
content to sit on this application
understood thanks very much Council
Curtis
thank you
um application
2201533 and 534
um this did come to Town Council and I'm
on the planning committee at Town
Council however I made it clear to the
chair at the time that I didn't take
part in the discussion or any votes I
come to this with an open mind thank you
understood thank you very much Council
Foreman
sorry I also need to declare that I'm a
conservative counselor at this election
but I do not know the applicant the same
as councilor Harvey understood thank you
very much anyone else
it's probably the longest part
blimey okay
um I think we've got minutes as well is
everyone happy with the minutes as
they're presented within the agenda pack
yeah agreed I'll sign those later on in
that case we can get to our first item
which is application reference
2201533 ful and
2201534 LBC this is York house on rather
Street and our presenting officer
Charlotte next Charlotte over to you
thank you chairman
so the site is indicated on the map by
the black circle the application site is
within the town center and Bill to Perry
boundary of Stratford
this slide shows the application site
edged in Black the site prints onto
Rother Street to the east projecting up
to Green Hill Street car park on the
western side
the red buildings are all listed
buildings with York house itself being
grade 2 listed the site is also in the
Conservation Area
so this is a full planning application
and listed building consent for the
Demolition and Redevelopment of the
large proportion of the site
the site plan at the top of this slide
shows the existing site layouts with the
proposed site plan shown below
much of the extensions to the rear of
the building would be demolished with a
commercial element being redeveloped in
total eight Newtown houses would be
created to the rear of the site
townhouses one to seven are would be
located along this part of the site with
this building now being proposed to be
converted into townhouse 8.
this element has been changed since
members last saw the applications
this slide shows the existing elevations
at the top of the screen with the
proposed elevations below
these elevations are as viewed from the
Green Hill Street Properties to the
um to the north of the site
you can see the first floor proposed
blade windows and reef Gardens
this slide shows the existing and
proposed elevations as viewed from the
playhouse and the Rother street car park
elevations to the South
this shows the atypical Reef design and
the glazing referred to in the report
this shows the proposed ground floor
plan showing the proximity to the
surrounding built form for example the
distances of approximately 2.6 meters
which is indicated by this red line here
from townhouse 4 to the wall on the
Northern side of the site and again the
red line on the southern part of the
site indicates approximately one meter
distance from the window to the
playhouse
so this slide shows the proposed first
floor you can see the proposed light
dwells on the southern elevation for
example here
and the one me 1.8 meter separation
distance which is again shown by the red
line from these first floor splade
window to the wall to the north
this slide shows the proposed second
floor including the changes to town
house 8 on the left-hand side of the
screen
so this photo is taken from Brother
Street showing the modest two-story
buildings including the front elevation
of York house
this photo is taken from Green Hill
Street showing The Pedestrian access
into the site you can see two of the
nearby Health Food takeaways within that
photo with the playhouse being visible
in the background and number 34
Greenhill Street on the right hand side
ashamed by the arrow this photo is taken
from the alleyway to the north of the
printing works the proposed Windows of
concern would be on the left hand side
of the photo facing onto the wall and a
two-story build form on the right hand
side
so as shown by the arrow this photo has
taken further along the alleyway looking
back to the rear elevation of York house
the windows on the townhouses will now
be on the right hand side facing the
wall on the left hand side
this photo is showing the relationship
to the buildings on Green Hill streets
you can also see the existing extract
flu
and this photo shows the sudden
elevation of the printing works on the
left with the playhouse on the right
hand side
so this indicates the separation
distance of one meter from the proposed
the southern elevation to the the
playhouse
so just to clarify there are updates
within the update sheet including notice
that a member site visit was carried out
this afternoon
officer recommendation is to refuse full
planning permission for the reason set
out on pages 24 and 25 and to Grant list
of building consent subject to their
conditions on those on pages 25 and 26
of the agenda thank you chairman
Sean thank you very much indeed let's
call our first speakers of the evening
who are our applicants and agents so we
have Gail Collins first of all please
Mel Kang Phil Powell Martin Court and
Richard Hardy I believe
I'm not sure we've got enough
microphones
now Ms Collins I'm gonna assume that
you're going to be doing the majority
they're speaking everyone else is here
to answer questions is that correct
fabulous in that case when you're all
set come from ready to go you'll have
three minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning when you're ready the floor's
yours
good evening
This Town Center site currently houses
an industrial building and a two-story
flat roofed office extension on the back
of a listed building in the conservation
area it's residential Redevelopment is
supported by your policy
the Town Council and the local councilor
are supportive there are no objections
from your planning policy highways
drainage fire service or other
consulties
at the heart of this proposal is the
refurbishment of York house it will be
occupied by the applicant as his main
office bringing employment and life back
into this empty listed building
the amended scheme is comparable in
height and bulk to The Print Works but
its footprint is set back the office
extension will be demolished opening up
the site your conservation officer is
supportive confirming that the revised
scheme reduces the intensity and
oppressive impact of the original larger
scheme and the Amendments lessen the
impact on the listed building and its
setting historic England have deferred
consideration to your conservation
officer and the listed building consent
is recommended for approval
it's therefore surprising that the
planning application is recommended for
refusal on the grounds that the scheme
fails to preserve the character and
appearance of the conservation area
objection to the lack of historic
architectural features is interesting
when the playhouse extension next door
is unashamedly modern a pasty should not
work here and your policy does not
require it roof Gardens are accepted by
your policies
the planning balance needs to be
properly weighed up the buildings are
becoming increasingly derelict and have
an unrestricted General industrial use
the proposal will rejuvenate the area
removing buildings that do not
contribute to the significance of the
conservation area or the setting of the
listed building it will ensure the
future of York house add to the Town
Center's vitality and create new housing
in this highly sustainable location
in terms of immunity planning conditions
relating to noise and hours of operation
do exist on the Green Hill Street
Properties the site is surprisingly
quiet there is no significant impact
from noise and any concerns can be
mitigated your development requirements
SPD says that non-opening windows are
acceptable in certain situations
situations and the scheme proposes
passive ventilation which allows fresh
air but stops noise only a limited
number of Windows on the North elevation
will be sealed in terms of daylight and
sunlight National policy confirms that
when considering Housing Council should
take a flexible approach when applying
the bre Guidance the main living areas
of the townhouses are on the upper
floors which comfortably comply with the
guidelines and the ground floor rooms
are double aspect 30 seconds founding
buildings are not all two stories
implied in the update report and the
measurements in the updated report are
incorrect
overlooking to Grove house is highly
unlikely due to the nearly 90 degree
angle and its nearest ground floor
window being obscure glazed overlooking
to 34 Greenhill street is also unlikely
due to the angles but the window in
townhouse 7 has a dual aspect and could
be obscure glazed the roof Terraces at
high level are distant in public views
and will not be overlooked in summary
this is an attractive creative scheme
with significant public benefits we're
happy to answer any questions thank you
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions please councilor
Parry first
thank you chair and good evening
um I would just like to declare that I
attended the site visit this afternoon
um I noticed the fire service have made
no objection could you possibly explain
um and give some information in the
event of such an event
on the basis there's no vehicle access
to the site the the arrangements for
fire service and also bin collection
please
sorry folks technology beats me again
um one of the queries that we're raised
by the fire service during the
um the consideration of the scheme it
was whether or not we met the 45 meter
limit to the length of hoses
um we were able to show that if a fire
engine or fire Appliance is parked in
Green Hill Street we can actually meet
the 45 meter limit furthest point that a
hose will will reach so in other words
all the rooms within each of the
um the dwellings will be reached by a
hose and then therefore
um it meets their requirements
and again with the with the waste
collection sorry Arrangements yeah waste
collection
um we have a central
uh collection point for the commercial
and residential waste and the intention
is that on collection days those bins
are moved so that they are closer to the
uh to Green Hill Street where the refuse
Lorry will park up and they'll collect
the bins from from there
fabulous thank you very much cancer
Crump
thank you
um you mentioned the separation
distances in the update sheet that
weren't correct
um could you give us an update on why
you think they're Incorrect and and
their significance please
it isn't of great significance but we
just wanted to to
um correct one dimension that had been
given which was 2.6 meters is actually
2.9 meters and I've since this was
something that was raised during the
visit and I've since had it checked
digitally and it's 2.9 meters it's of
little significance really but it that
is the correct dimension
sorry can I also add that um I think the
implication is that the surrounding
development is two-story in height to
adjacent to this site but actually in
practice the heights are not two-story
there are some two-story elements but
largely things are single story
including
um the the extension to the playhouse
immediately to the south of the site at
that point it is single story as are the
rear of the Green Hill Street Properties
okay thank you very much Council Harvey
thank you
the case officer has written in her
report that she believes that this is a
development which is of high density
could you illuminate to me what your
understanding of the high density
development might be please
um I don't think we've worked out
exactly what the density is on on the
proposal but
um the scheme has reduced down from um
where originally it was 16. we're down
to eight dwellings now
um over the course of pre-ap and the
planning application
um but in terms of planning policy
the location is one that supports high
density development because it is a
highly sustainable location and in our
opinion this is appropriate for the site
okay
lots of Curtis please
um you said that the um
rear of the playhouse is a single story
but can you tell us what the height of
the playhouse is
the the elevation which is nearest to
the rear of our development is single
story it's a tall single story and this
would this is going to have to be a
guess but I'm guessing it's probably
about four meters to the to the eaves
maybe a little a little bit less than
that but it's it so it you might argue
it's a story and a half but it's a
single story building I can if you give
me a few minutes I could probably
actually measure something to give you a
more accurate answer
but it's yeah it's but it's a single
story
thank you very much members do we have
any other questions for any of our
guests right now no in that case ladies
and gentlemen thank you very much for
your time and contribution this evening
right let's call our next speaker who is
counselor Jenny franchley
good evening councilor for actually
um and I'm sure you understand the drill
we have you'll have five minutes I'll
give you a 30 second one before your
time is up otherwise whenever you're
ready the floor is yours
thank you very much
um
I'm here again just put to support this
Innovative and elegant solution to
developing an historic town center
the listed building will be renovated
and refurbished and brought back to an
economic use as as our beautiful
historic buildings should be but not
only that an intriguing backlan space
its full function as a print work long
over will become comfortable stylish and
sustainable dwellings for residents
the development has been reduced in
units once more to seven in the main
block and the two townhouses will now
actually become warm and will be housed
in the existing brick block
reducing the impact on the car park and
the nearby townhouse
it has gained listed building consent
and will become an asset to the town
Pages 11 to 13 principal development
every paragraph in that in your papers
is in support of development
concerns Center on the impact on the
Town Center through density height and
local distinctiveness
I visited the site on a number of
occasions I pass it frequently and I've
tried to Envision the impact of
Greenhill Street
townhouse and Grove house and the car
park
when you stand on the pavement and look
up it's a narrow and you've hardly see
anything of the building behind the
buildings in Greenhill Street you can
Glimpse down the uh the passageway and
if you go into the car park at the back
you can actually see elements of the new
development from there
yes there will be glimpses of the new
pitched roof and flat roofs and roof
Gardens but only glimpses little more
than what can be seen now from the
Pavements
I would ask you to consider if these
glimpses warrant a refusal for such a
stylish development
density has been reduced further and as
I would contend compatible with Town
Center living
I welcome suitable contemporary designs
in our town we should build where
appropriate buildings that reflect our
age
especially where green technologies are
concerned and sustainability
I hope your site visit this afternoon
has answered your concerns and that you
can now support the refurbishment of the
listed building and the provision of
eight well-appointed and green
apartments with cycle facilities
may I just say as well that the time
Council was fully supported of this
development and still is supportive of
this development
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions councilor Parry first
please thank you good evening councilor
fragile
um can you advise was the support by the
Town Council unanimous
foreign
if you can remember
I
I can't actually
actually because it is compatible with
the um our neighborhood plan
anyone else
no in that case tragically thank you
very much for time contribution
okay uh we will now move to punch
clarification with our officers does
anyone have any points that they need
clarifying councilor Harvey please
chairman I should have mentioned that I
too attended the site visit this
afternoon
um question to the
case officer could you help me out
understand
the concept of density are there
measures is this on what basis have you
come to your conclusion that this is a
densely developed site
so when we're looking at the density
we're purely looking at
um
the amount of development in a certain
area as opposed to how that then relates
to the character of the surrounding area
so for example this development
um whilst it does have the commercial
element as well it would be assessed at
around about 80 dwellings per hectare
which is
um in terms of
obviously we've got the commercial side
of the development so that would that
would actually reduce part of the site
area down
um looking at the surrounding townscape
and the the character of the area though
whilst it is within the town center of
Stratford it is on the outskirts of the
the Town Center boundary and the
development is generally at a lower
level in terms of the the
um level of development on each site in
particular obviously we that we would
then look at other aspects so
um the fact that this is a background
development and that it should be
subservient to the main parts of the um
the built the dominant buildings which
front onto Green Hill Street and also to
Rother Street as well and how the
development itself fits in without
looking at you know the amount of open
space that's proposed as part of the
scheme as well
um so that there's a number of factors
that we would look at when we're looking
at the impacts on the character and the
intensification of the site which is
going from being used by one one user at
the moment to obviously a commercial use
plus the the eight dwellings as well
you can follow up yeah thank you very
much thank you for that
um
the design for this proposal might be
described as innovative
and it's in a Conservation Area
could you explain the relationship
between the constraints and requirements
of a Conservation Area
and the Innovative nature of the design
of this building please
so the conservation area is a Heritage
asset in its own right completely
separate from the impact on any listed
buildings so when we're looking at the
conservation area we have to look at the
key characteristics that you'd find in
that area itself which are things like
the two-story modest developments going
down to design features such as chimneys
and particular architectural design
features as well which officers don't
consider to be replicated within the
design itself whilst we
look for when we're assessing impacts on
Heritage assets we would either want
them to preserve or to enhance the
Heritage asset in this case the design
whilst contemporary it's not something
that we would consider to be reflective
of the key features of the conservation
area in particular the features such as
the unusual roof type and the glazing
for the for the Gardens and then things
like displayed windows at first floor
level these aren't things that are
characteristic of the conservation area
and the historic townscape and then as
well as that we've also got the lack of
features that we would typically look to
find in the conservation areas such as
as chimneys and other historical
features so it's looking at all those
factors together to see whether this
development in itself would either
preserve or enhance the conservation
area and whether it's fitting with the
The Wider area that the character of the
area that it would sit within as well
can I just ask members to consider
before deciding that this development is
innovative
to decide why they think it's Innovative
rather than just different
um different to what's normally in in
Stratford but not necessarily Innovative
nationally
I'm sure members will bear that in mind
councilor Curtis please thank you um
this may be something to explore in
debate but I'm just wondering Charlotte
you said that this is on the outskirts
of the Town Center boundary could you
say where you feel the Town Center
boundary lies in that case
so the York house was originally
um towards the outskirts of the the town
itself
um when we look back at the historic
usage of the the building and how the
usage has changed over time I believe
the Town Center boundary now is
um up towards Albany Road along that
area
it's clarification before we go to
debate let's move to debate who'd like
to kick us off councilor Parry please
thank you chair
um I think for those members who
attended the site visit I think this is
a classic example and a very good reason
why we actually deferred the application
from January
it is a very tight sight
um but it is also surrounded by an
Eclectic mix of different buildings from
different ages spanning
a number of centuries we've even got
um glimpses of views towards sort of
1970s architecture
um
I found the site visit actually really
really quite quite helpful from looking
putting it into perspective but also
looking at the views because one of the
key things the
um
planning officer has highlighted is all
around the character of the area around
it and also the impact on the heritage
of the actual site now we know the
frontage of York house is is to be
refurbished so retaining all the
historical features
um but the actual public views from
Green Hill Street when you're actually
standing in Green Hill Street and you're
looking up an Alleyway and it's not a
vehicle access it's actually quite wide
so it's a a pedestrian access into
rather the the car park which sits
behind the playhouse
if you move towards into a you can't see
anything if you're sitting if you're
standing in Green Hill Road you can't
see anything of the development or
hardly will hardly see anything apart
from a few rooftops and then when you go
into rather the the car park looking
back a bit beyond the playhouse you can
hardly see any of that development
either
um I think it's
I think it's important that we listen
to local opinion and I think if the Town
Council have come forward to support it
the ward member has come forward to
support it I'm struggling to see any
significant harm to the character of the
area because it's it's so well hidden it
is backland but it is so well hidden but
most importantly what we are trying to
do with climate change is have
sustainable developments and this is a
collection of seven townhouses plus a
separate dwelling that are small and
ideally suited for people who don't have
cars but are right in the center of the
Town walking distance and therefore on a
number of points I believe it ticks a
lot of boxes and I would like to propose
that we Grant uh planning permission
particularly in view of the local
support and because of I I don't believe
it it has an impact on the character the
area because it is so well hidden thank
you thank you councilor Perry just to
confirm are you proposing for the full
and the LBC or just one or the other yes
both marbles thank you very much cancer
seraphim please thank you chair
um I haven't got much to say I totally
agree with councilor Perry on this thank
you
short but sweet Council Curtis thanks
very much yeah I I agree with the
council Perry we're very happy to to
Second her proposal I think although
this is in a historic area
the the building designs around there
are a real hodgepodge and I have to say
I mean having worked in the Art House on
many occasions it really isn't the most
historically architecturally beautiful
building in the town I can't see that
this would have this development would
have any negative impact on the
surroundings and as Council Perry says
it's barely visible from the from the
highways thank you
thank you very much
um would anyone else like say anything
in debate cancer Harvey I'm of the
opposite point of view
um I my perception is that this is high
density it's very high identity at 80
even 80 units per hectare uh
the distances between buildings is
inadequate
the design may not be Innovative and I'm
grateful for Mr Barker for picking me up
on that
um but it to me it is contemporary to
the point of being an unusual and I
don't see that it sits well with the
remainder of the conservation area
um I hear what others say but to my to
my eye and to my perception
this Prospect offends my eye and I I see
good reasons why the case officer has
come to her conclusions we haven't
mentioned the objection from
Environmental Health at all normally
when the statutory
consultee objects we take notice of that
so
um I hear what others have said I shall
vote against
are you making a counter proposal or are
you just making your thoughts known
I think I'm astute enough to be able to
say I'm just making my thoughts known
good man okay cancer Adam please
uh thank you chair um one of the things
that I picked up when the applicant was
speaking was about the possibility of
doing some additional
um glaze Windows to protect the
overlooking as outlined as one of the
reasons number four for refusal if we
were minded to go against the officer's
decision I'd like to see that condition
added
to protect those views please
understood thank you um I'm gonna move
this slightly backwards and go to points
of clarification so
Charlotte just so we're clear which
windows are you referring to in
um reasons refusal for which particular
areas just like we are of understanding
so one of the windows which is of
concern is this window at first floor
level which is facing towards a bedroom
window on number 34 Green Hill Street so
that's the 10.3 separation distance
oh sorry sorry so it's from this side of
the window here so the Spade window
facing towards the bedroom window on 34
Green Hill Street which is a 10.3 meter
distance
and the other windows
[Music]
um
it's just off to the side of the screen
but it's the windows on on this left
hand side of the elevation here on
townhouse eight
and in fact um so I was on site visit if
I remember rightly that on townhouse
eight that is that would be lower level
so would in essence any condition to
obscure glaze be obscure glazing a
essentially a living room are we okay to
do that I thought it typically would be
bathrooms that we would have to
calculated
bear with us chair this is a little bit
fiddly but we'll uh we'll show it in a
moment
so the other windows which are mentioned
in the report are these windows along
this side of the elevation here facing
towards Grove house
so this is a three room
um so there is a window here but that
does look out onto the patio area so
there is there is some shading there as
well
and then these the windows for the the
dining area
and the the kitchen as well
would it be acceptable for a condition
to be put on to obscure glaze the
windows that access that are used for
the dining stroke living area
chairman um we're recommending refusal
remember uh if members think it's
acceptable to do that that's a decision
that's in their remit in there the
question is more on policy terms in
policy terms you don't have a problem if
we were minded to do that there is no
policy preventing that but we consider
that it's a very full living environment
and therefore recommending not to
hmm Council Adam would you like to say
anything further on your what you have
just put
oh thank you chair
um
yeah I'm definitely sure about one of
them but the other one I'm maybe not so
comfortable with the living in um room
peace but
that might be a bit more debate there
perhaps
okay
um cancer Kendall yeah it's directly on
what you've said there I've got a I
don't know I'm uncomfortable with the
idea of the Obscure glazing on a living
room I think what I think
which is I think the applicant would
come back and say it's unreasonable and
then Appeal on that basis I think I
think and I think that would be fair if
they came back and said it was
unreasonable so my feeling is probably
my living room the obscuredly is not
appropriate
okay
um
one could potentially put obscure
glazing a condition the obscio glazing
for the upper floors of these seven if
you're minded is that I'm getting the
feeling that that's ultimately what you
want to get to
I have no second cancer agreed yeah yeah
okay so
um it comes closers do you want to talk
on this particular issue go ahead just
to ensure that
um because the the living areas the
sitting rooms are on the first floor so
no in this particular house or on the
ground floor aren't they just want to
make sure we've got their flaws in the
right order it is somewhat confusing and
um so if I'm and correct me if I get
this wrong the ground floor
um I understand to be kitchen and dining
sort of Area Middle floor bedrooms top
floor living area
oh
obscuring the right ones I sincerely
hope so
Council Parry given you made the initial
proposal are you happy with that being
added as a condition
I got a little bit confused if you can
with the I don't I would not be happy
with an obscure window from a living
room
oh dear this is all getting very
complicated again so um I think might
certainly my issue would have been the
uh putting obscure glazing on the ground
floor of the other building so not the
ones that are on our screen this one on
the bottom left now on our screens
um so we're ignoring that I think the um
in particular uh reason four for refusal
refers to the windows on the top floor
which would be
living room
of these uh townhouses uh in particular
the one that overlooks is it did you say
34 Green Hill Street I think it was
so townhouse seven looks towards the
Edgefield Green Hill Street yes
in particular that one has been named in
the region for refusal but I think
though it's those windows but again
we're talking a living area
I'm slightly uncomfortable if I'm honest
sorry I'm not comfortable with the
obscure
glazing in a living area it's
inappropriate understood
okay
um
you've heard reasons to go against your
officer's recommendation are you content
that you have appropriate and sufficient
reasons for us to move forward to a vote
I'm sorry chair I now need some
clarification what have we resolved over
obscure glazing
uh to secure have we resolved no obscure
places no obscure glazing it has not
been put as a recommendation okay so
members have resolved that
um in terms of design in terms of
density and in terms of immunity for
future occupiers and in terms of
overlooking they are satisfied that this
scheme is acceptable in all those those
terms in which case I am happy to to
accept that you have made a planning
judgment and uh have a proper planning
reason to to Grant permission if that's
what you wish to do I understood thank
you we haven't quite resolved yet um so
we will hopefully be able to do that now
so members um you've do we need to go
through conditions first we probably
should shouldn't we before we move to a
vote
we have quite a literature
um
I'm not convinced unless you tell me
otherwise Charlotte I'm not convinced
that there's anything unusual or
remarkable in there I think we can do
that between ourselves and you chair if
you're content to do that
I am cancer power are you contempt for
me to disaster proposer uh forget who's
second in that was it yourself against
Curtis
um your content for me to do that okay
in that case proposal is to Grant this
is for the full application first of all
proposal is to Grant um against officer
recommendation for the reasons given can
I show if Hansel is in favor of granting
eight eight and those against
one so committee therefore resolves to
Grant application 2201533 ful could I we
of course had the same proposal uh for
the LBC and I'm assuming seconded by
cancer Curtis could I please have a show
of hands please in favor of granting the
LBC
oh
okay eight and those against
one so committee therefore resolves to
Grant application twenty two zero one
five three four l b c
marvelous
um let's move on to our next application
which is application reference
2200182 out that is land off Walton Road
in wellsborn our presenting officer will
be Joe Brook as soon as he sat down and
comfortable so Joe whenever you're ready
the floor is yours
thanks chair
the application site is located on the
edge of walesbourne as it indicated by
the black dot before you
the application is for 10 cell phone
custom build plots
as highlighted in the officers report
the application site is situated outside
the defined buab within open Countryside
as determined by policy
but is included when the site allocation
plan preferred options for the
development of southern coast building
housing
as you can see the plum before you just
so you get some indication see if we get
the good
that is Pro sd122
this is pro sd12a this is Walton
roadling down the site this is Lowe's
Lane and these is a pedestrian axis at
least into the site
that is the console at the edge of the
wells one Conservation Area
this is more to give an indication of
the imagery from Google Earth as you can
clearly see Walton Road running down
here this is the application site itself
Lowe's Lane running across the
pedestrian access as proposed will be
roughly situated between that parcel
there with the buildings the proud leads
they're in this area along the edge of
the site boundary and into the adjacent
field and then back along Walton Road as
you can see there's been a construction
of a lot of new houses in within this
area with a new industrial stays over
the recent years
the application site is 1.5 hectares of
Greenfield London located on the Eastern
Edge the site provides a single larger
field and the only building situated is
a small corrugated metal storage
structure located in the block of scrub
on the Northern boundary I'll just go
back to show that it's in there
the overall cycle is relative flat
agricultural field with wildfire and
barrages conversion of fencing hedging
trees scrub vegetation
I'll set out in the officer report the
submitted design code contained with the
design and access statement sets out the
development principles considerations
and perimeters taken to account the
local context and character of the area
this includes the use of suitable
material separation distances building
lines active frontages and Boundary
treatments if granted any forthcoming
Reserve matters applications would need
to cord with its design code
once again for reference this is the
pros plot layouts so this would be the
build area of each individual plot
the prowl is indicated running down
alongside of the boundary of the site
Walton Road which would be the main
access point there would be a POS
situated with a stud
sustainable Urban drainage system on the
Northern areas of sites and this is The
Pedestrian route through
the Woodland would be used as adjacent
to the field in the river then which I
will get back onto in two seconds
this map indicates uh the agricultural
land classification this area here is
the only gray to our culture land
classification as defined by defra and
Natural England the rest of the site is
defined as an urban Edge area it's
roughly about 290 square meters and it
is in within the officers report
this is the application site and you can
see it within the area so this is taken
from Google Images coming in so you've
got the boundary of where I was born
just there that's the side area it gives
the best context that's what I've used
this imagery
this is a site from Walton Road as
taking by myself so it gives you area
you see the edges of the behinder and
the development just beyond
this is from the pro
so you're looking down Walton Road over
the road there that's the edge of world
war in which the uppercase site were
back onto
this is Walton Road Lee into worldsborne
as you can see why the arrow
this is The Pedestrian access the black
circle indicates roughly where the photo
has been indicated have been taken
looking that's these nights on Lowes
rain this photo leads into the
application side
this is Walton Road against for the
accesses purposes the black line
indicates we're a black circle sorry
indicates right to the photos so coming
in and out of Walton Road that's the in
the business units just opposite the
sides
and this is for relative context the
Australian area so you can see the
predominant materials red brick but
there is white rendering Factory from in
the area
I will highlight one more thing and I'll
go about to just do that is the setup in
the office report the area is within
made NDP in an area of river then a
significant value views so there's a
corridor that leads all the way out into
the open Countryside but as sat on the
office report I have found there to be
moderate arm to this
um proposal
and in conclusion
report having considered the area's
development plan all relevant material
planning considerations and the level of
weight which can be attributed
to both adopted an emerging policy as
sat down paragraph 48 the framework on
balance I consider the principal
development is acceptable and that this
outweighs the moderate landscape arm
which I have identified officer
recommendation is therefore Grant
Subject condition and notes and section
106 obligation set out in the report as
you will indicate on the update sheet
there is two updates one is in respect
to the designer access statement simply
its amendment to reflect the latest plan
proposal layout the other one is on
officer recommendation basically the 106
to be agreed within six months whether
it is if the development is approved
thank you
Joe thank you very much indeed let's
call our first speaker and so I don't
know who is councilor and Pryor of
wellsborn and Walton Parish Council good
evening councilor prior
you've been here before so you know the
deal three minutes I'll give you a 30
second warning when you're ready the
floor is yours
um good evening thank you the council
objects this planning application on a
number of grounds firstly it's against
our neighborhood plan and it's also
outside the built-up boundary identified
within that plan the ability is to be on
previously arable lands some of which is
high grade
your officer has clearly stated that
this proposed site is not in accord with
cs15 cs16 as10 Norwell number seven of
the neighborhood plan this proposal is
not community-led and so again does not
occurred with these policies
numerous ways in which his development
does not occurred with either your car
strategy or our made neighborhood plan I
made in this report but each time
they're qualified by a rider with the
neighborhood plan does not contain an
identified area for self or custom
builds but then neither does the core
strategy stay this explicitly to use the
officer's words
when the parish council set out its
neighborhood plan neither Stratford
District Council nor the inspector who
approved it made any mention of this
deficiency
we do not therefore see why all the very
valid reasons for refusing this
application hang on this one thread it
is being proposed that our neighborhood
plan should have a coast and horse sent
through it to meet this unrecognized
efficiency
the application furthermore does not
meet the provision of an off-road
walking or cycle route to Lowe's Lane
the reason for that provision was that
from the end of Lowe's Lane to ettington
Road there is a foot way and the
condition of providing a footwear
identified in your proposal scb12 to
improve Walton Road between the site
access and its Junction with Lowes Lane
including the provision of a footwear
and I would emphasize that it says from
the site access not from the far end of
the development would have made up a
joint uproot thereby making a safe
pedestrian access to the facilities near
this development namely a supermarket a
bus stop the Leisure provision and
school transport
the proposed pedestrian route from this
development lands The Pedestrian in the
middle of Lowe's Lane nowhere close to
these facilities and is merely we would
suggest a way to circumvent the
requirement SDC placed when designating
this plot of land for sale for custom
build despite the parish's objection at
the time that this was not appropriate
as it was contrary to our neighborhood
plan
on page 21 of the officer's report he
states that quote the sap and policies
therein are afforded limited weight at
this time however on page 22 he states
that he affords moderate weight to the
fact that the application does not
occurred with all the various CS ones
and the ww7 of the neighborhood plan 30
seconds
the parish council would suggest that
this failure to Accord with these
policies gives greater wage not moderate
way to our objections to this
development
he also states that in light of the
Stratford landscape sensitivity
assessment that this site has a medium
to a high level of sensitivity in
respect to housing
the understanding of the parish council
is that made neighborhood plans carry
some considerable weight when
considering applications and to ignore
it negates all the input from residents
about the area within which they live in
conclusion I would state that there is
sufficient evidence in the officer's
report and in the objections made by
ourselves to this development to show
that is in the wrong place that is
contrary to both the neighborhood plan
and your own core strategy and for these
reasons I ask that you object that you
reject this application
thank you very much I've let you run
over a couple of seconds to finish your
conclusion so I'm going to have to offer
those seconds to other people as well
just so we're clear members do we have
any questions for councilor priorities
Council Andrew Serafin first thank you
chair good evening
um have you done a recent housing survey
in your area
in terms of what in terms of a rented
accommodation in terms of housing
uh in terms of what type of housing is
needed in your area we have looked at it
and the need on the whole is for
affordable rented accommodation
and it's for three bedroom affordable
rented accommodation that is the
greatest need that we have in our
community okay okay thank you Council
Parry please
thank you good evening councilor
um you mentioned uh the agricultural
land was particularly high grade do you
know what particular level of grade it
might be
I gather the part of his level three I'm
not absolutely certain I've eaten but
it's on your small part as the officer
said the rest was just general arable
land we recognize that
the questions members
no in that case can't surprise thank you
very much your time contribution
okay let's move to our next speakers who
are our applicant and agents so we have
Reuben Bellamy and we have Andy now
forgive me forget your surname
pronunciation Run is it moja
smashed it thank you
that's a relief
now gentlemen who's going to be doing
the speaking or are you going to split
between the two of you
could you pop your microphone on when
you speak if you wouldn't mind
yeah um Andy's going to be doing the
speaking and I'm here for questions if
anybody has them after he's done his
speech thank you very much perfect in
that case Andy you'll have three minutes
and seven seconds when you're ready the
floor's yours thank you chair
I'd like to begin by commending your
council's case officer Mr Brooke for
their diligence professionalism and hard
work throughout the applications passage
to committee
and this application began in January
2022 as a proposed development of 14
custom-built homes which align with the
direction of travel of the emerging site
allocations plan at that time
the following consultation a series of
Amendments have been made to the scheme
to reflect comments received by
statutory consulties such as planning
policy highways and ecology to remedy
the issues raised now these have all
been addressed in full to the
satisfaction of those consultees and
there's no neither an in-principle
policy objection and nor are there any
outstanding technical objections from
consorties
the application now aligns with the
changes that the task and finish group
proposed to the emerging site
allocations plan having been reduced to
the provision of templates for custom
build now this reduced number of
dwellings also results in reduced
landscape impacts an increased level of
green infrastructure on site
and existing boundary hedgerows and
trees are retained and enhanced a newly
planted Orchard is proposed on site and
an 11.8 biodiversity net gain is
achieved on site
provision is also made on site for a
children's play facility
now the application is framed by a
design code which all Reserve matters
applications have to Accord with and
that means that the council retains that
element of control over a prospective
custom Builders to ensure that the
proposals are appropriate to the site's
context
the council's 10-year housing land
Supply is not challenged here but the
legal duty to meet self-built registered
demand is separate to that and the
council's January 2023 self and custom
build demand and Supply briefing note
identified a shortfall of 76 plots
against the council statutory Duty
defined in the 2015 Act
the Welford appeal reduced that
shortfall to 66 plots and last week 15
plots were approved at Halford
this would contribute another 10 plots
towards that shortfall and assist the
Council with meeting its statutory Duty
there's a growing number of appeal
decisions whereby statutory Duty failure
has resulted in self and custom build
applications being awarded substantial
weight in the planning balance
sufficient to outweigh development plan
conflict
this application is in accordance with
the emerging site allocations plan and
the applicants have worked closely with
your officers to ensure that issues
raised have been responded to and
addressed promptly
it's therefore respectfully requested
that members follow the officer's
recommendation and approve this
application subjects completion of
section 106 agreement and conditions
we're happy to answer any questions
thank you
marvelous thank you very much indeed
well within your time members do we have
any questions for either our applicant
or agent
Council Curtis please thank you
um
I'd like to ask probably a rather naive
question
um
if I wanted to buy one of these plots
and have a two-bedroom Bungalow built on
that would that be possible
um yes the parameters plan the design
code will set out a limit in terms of
height so if you didn't want to which
would be too story in this location but
if you wanted to build a single story
marvelous anyone else
no in that case gentlemen thank you both
for your time and contribution this
evening
okay let's move to our final speaker on
this item is counselor Kendall
seems strange to have you set that end
councilor Kendall but you still you know
the drill you'll have five minutes I'm
gonna give you an extra 70 seconds
um and I'll give you 30 second warning
when you're ready I don't think I need
the full five minutes but you're right
it's strange being at this end of the
table right okay um I'll begin I want to
start off by congratulating the
applicants uh on a really really good
consultation process it's right you know
it's rare that actually you get
um
a developer come along and engage both
with me as Ward member and with the
Parish Council on several occasions that
was fantastic and they deserve full
congratulations for that
however I'm afraid I can't support the
application this application is before a
snack purely because SDC does not yet
have enough
self and custom build uh housing
available
therefore in this situation because of
the national policy the presumption I
think I'm right to say is in favor of
Grant
it is my view though that if this was
not the case and this application was
come toward before us in any other
condition we would not be recommending
grant for this application
um it's outside of the built-up area
boundary it's an open Countryside it is
also heavily contrary to the welshpool
neighborhood plan neighborhood plans
have got to mean something otherwise
there's really no point making them and
this was this field was gone over many
many times but I during that during a
planning process and every time it was
decided that it was not appropriate for
housing
if we look at the application itself we
will carefully look while I like many
aspects of the proposal for the you know
for sustainable and green housing which
is what is likely to come forward later
on a full application
I find that actually the application
site is just wholly unsuitable for
housing Walton Lane is a narrow stretch
of highway
um
I used to go cycling a lot around there
and over the years I've become less and
less comfortable riding those lanes
because of
um
obscured Vision regarding the
hedging and the fact that cars travel
along very very quickly it is not really
a double lane every car has to slow down
to pass and when you're on a bike it's
even more terrifying because the cars
don't slow down this is not the right
stretch of road to be putting more
houses onto
um
and on top of that I mean I suppose it's
even you know you can tell indeed the
highways have only removed their
planning their objection based on
substantial conditions that are noted in
your agenda agenda pack today
um regarding Visual splays and all the
various things that will need to be done
including the footpaths and including
the fact that footpaths will have to be
completed before uh for occupation of
the houses and all of this
it's clear to me that highways although
they've now raised no objection subject
conditions it's clear to me that
highways clearly did have a problem with
this at one point and I think that's
something we should be listening to
um
at least I feel these other channels
actually yes these other changes I want
to say will also lead to a real change
in the character of Walton Lane the the
amount of hedging that will be removed
will change the rural setting and uh
image and the uh of Walter Lane forever
not to mention the impact it'll have on
wildlife and the importance of hedging
to Wildlife look consequently I feel
that the application is like it's nice I
like it I think these are they should be
done in certain places but the place has
got to be the right place it's got to be
the right location and therefore I think
this is is the wrong location for this
based on what I've said so far
um what am I asking the committee to do
first of all I'm asking the committee to
reject the application outright tonight
because I don't think it's appropriate
however if you think that actually
you're not sure not sure I would ask the
committee to consider deferring this for
a site visit so that you can all stand
on Walton Lane very carefully and hope
that nothing comes swinging around in
your corners but you could then see the
site access for yourselves and you'd
perhaps see where I'm coming from on
this thank you
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions for our award member
no marvelous in that case cancel thank
you very much
okay let's move to points for
clarification with our officers does
anyone have a point for clarifying
councilor Eden first please
thank you chair
um I wondered Joe could you just
um highlight on that map that will do um
where the protected view is on the NDP
if you know please
yeah to be honest I can do better or not
all of those things
uh this Pioneer shows the protected
clicked off it shows objective let me
try and I don't know what it keeps doing
nice for everything
it's that green Corridor that is
protective view so if you see the
application site here right on the edge
that is the green Corridor the
protective view the rather than
cockrador
thank you very much Council Harvey
please
uh thank you chairman
um we all know this
um area of self-development is a
fast-moving
area of Planning Development there is a
decision an appeal decision yesterday
and I'd like to ask the officers two
questions
um in relation to that that decision one
it was a a decision in the case of a
permission in principle is that
comparable to the application in front
of us and secondly had the officer had
the benefit of this decision uh at the
time he wrote his report would this
decision have made any difference just
to make it plain this is a decision for
self-build four plots which was refused
by an officer
the applicant appealed and the inspector
dismissed the appeal
we're going to do this as a tag team
chairman
in answer to the first question on while
aware of the appeal decision but you
have to take it into the process so
permission in principle is a new sort of
thing that's been brought in by
government
uh the theory is it will speed up
planning permissions the first stage of
a permission in principle is literally
as a principle acceptable in that case
it was in Greenbelt area which I
appreciate the inspector did say he
regarded as in-filled plots but it
wasn't adjacent to any built a pair of
boundaries it wasn't a replacement dwell
in and it was directly in the open gun
side so unlike this where we do have
some policy guidance given the sap but
limited weight the principal was never
acceptable it would that's why the
officer recommended refusal in that
basis so yesterday's determination on
permission and principle wasn't
acceptable also there is an issue
regarding permission and principles
where you have to do plan and
obligations to satisfy custom build it
that that was also not satisfied so it
wouldn't have changed my determination
for this application it's a different
process and one for that process wasn't
acceptable in that area this on balance
in the waiting and so forth throughout
my report is why I've determined this is
acceptable so it wouldn't have changed
my conclusion I can confirm that
as my part of this this tag team chair
can I first of all say thank you very
much to councilor Harvey for giving us
advance notice of this question because
it's it's allowed us to give him a
fuller answer than we would otherwise
have been able to do at short notice
because that appeal decision did only up
rival yesterday afternoon
um
so as a general comment I think it's
important to say that our understanding
of this type of development is evolving
daily
for that very reason but there's no
evidence to suggest that the appeal
decisions we've received so far show
that we're taking the wrong approach
planning isn't a ticks tick box exercise
it involves planning judgment and in
this instance officers refuse the
application the the appeal officers
refuse the application under delegated
powers and the inspector dismissed the
appeal
as as Joe has said permissions in
principle are somewhat different to
outline permissions but in many ways
they're broadly comparable
um but what was really different about
this one was the the absence of this
section 106 obligation that has come
forward in this case uh that I think was
was absolutely determinative as far as
the inspector was concerned even if he
hadn't found on anything else he would
have found on that
um
so the conclusion that I come to is that
the inspector gave significant weight to
the location outside the built-up area
boundary but it was reduced by the
shortage of self and custom-built houses
given further weight by the absence of a
legal agreement uh the harm to the uh
special landscape area was given
significant weight and the overall black
planning balance was that in the
inspector's opinion the harm
significantly and demonstrably
outweighed the benefits of four
additional houses
we're going through a very similar
process here but we're coming to a
different conclusion and that's because
of the planning judgments involved
and I hope that rather long answer was
was helpful councilor Harvey
fabulous thank you very much cancer
Crump next please
thank you thanks to councilor Harvey so
my questions been partially answered on
on the planning appeals
um obviously it's a new area that is
evolving in Mr Barker is said that
um
what we can gather is we're not going
down the wrong route to you know we've
got the right approach
so I'm relatively happy about the the
planning appeals
um just one confirmation Joe is that
the objections from the highways a state
in the report have been removed for this
application
I can't I can't confirm they have been
removed what's probably also pertinent
was as the applicants highlighted this
originally came in as 14 units highways
if you go into a case folder was
consulted a number of times in one
response in the 14 units they recognized
the issues with well they State the
issues along that area Garden pedestrian
access and so forth but they highlight
the labor lead a lot of the issues can
be done through Section 278 works at
that point which regardless of if this
got planning permission
the applicants and the holidays would
have to sit down with each other and
make sure that it calls with the 278
agreements regardless of any permission
because that's another legislative
process
I appreciate Alex for 14 units but it
would still be the same process even for
the 10 units to make sure it's safe and
suitable in Hollywood standards
thank you very much Council Parry please
thank you chair
um
I want to go back to appeals if I may
Joe
um obviously we've had a number of
appeals on self-build sites in the
district over the last couple of years
are you aware of that that have been
on a number of them they've been over
they've been overturned they've been
allowed
are you aware of any of those that have
been allowed had a strong case in terms
of them of of weight being attributed to
the neighborhood development plan
not so much in this District there's
been a lot of appeals because the
problem being I'm going to be quite
blunt the problem being right now is
government brought this in to
legislation where the core strategy and
NDP is already made and they suddenly
told every Council across the country
you know other legal obligation to meet
cell phone custom build housing almost
immediately so straight away that kind
of overrides and we have to find
suitable sites or suitable ways bringing
these forward for that reason there has
been a number of appeals across the
country and other authorities where
there has been made ndps and so forth
which the inspector is gone you don't
have submissions plots even though there
isn't the made NDP and it is against
technically against adoptive policy but
because it is a legal obligation within
the custom build act you have this we
weigh heavily in favor not so much in
this District I have to be honest with
that one
thank you very much cancer Curtis
thanks chair
um Joe just another question I because I
obviously this is coming up more and
more frequently and there has been
debate in the past over
the the short for the size of the
shortfall in the Customs outboard
has Are We Now do we now have definitive
figures or is this are there still
question marks over that register if you
like
the worst response about a policy team
the one thing that I will say I I don't
we they register it they monitor it and
we go on the thing the seal part two and
it's been heavily scrutinized by
barrises and so forth the way of
registering it is been determined that
is probably the best way to indicate
what is coming for yourself and custom
build arcs
what I will say is the appeal statement
decisions that we have had recently in
all of them it was recognized that we
had an undisupply Applause non-ly
inspectors raised anything regarding the
numbers including the permission and
principle that was referenced yesterday
the inspector recognized there was an
undisplier part
marvelous thank you very much members we
have any other points of clarification
before we move to the debate
no let's move to debate who would like
to kick us off
councilor Eden
thank you chair
um
part of if I was reading um the uh
appeal yesterday correctly it was in
Studley so about 150 meters away from
where I live so I do know exactly where
it is
um
part of what was highlighted in that was
uh as a as a determining partly
determining Factor was the view now
studly doesn't have a made NDP
um but that view that is on that plot
was or is one that would be forthcoming
in that plan
to me
um
there is a made NDP with that view
specified in and this is taking that
away so that's against our policy so for
me I don't I don't feel comfortable in
supporting this at all
are you making a proposal just one clip
let's see what everyone else has got to
say understood cancer Curtis please
very much in agreement with the ward
member on this
um
it
I understand the difficulties around the
customer self-build Act
but at the same time it it doesn't
Accord with neighborhood plan
there are significant objections from
the parish council very eloquent reasons
for objection from the Ward member
um
I'm really on these and to me the so
often
I think neighborhood development plans
take a huge amount of work
to come to fruition
and I am as I've said in these meetings
before I know really concerned when we
make decisions that fly in the face of
those neighborhood development plans the
parish council objections so I I'm not
at all happy about approving this thank
you chair
um are you willing to make a proposal
don't feel pressured into it if you
don't want I think I'll need some more
games on
good planning grounds to refuse
understood councilor Harvey next please
we have been here before
I think the general sentiment amongst
members of the committee is generally
that we know that this is against our
core strategy policies we know that in
most instances this is going to be
against an NDP
but there is a statutory obligation on
us as far as the
self-filled and custom buildings Act is
concerned we have a deficit
I
and I've always said this with great
reluctance
unless there is some other Factor as
there was in this studly case of of the
um the Vista that was going to be lost
had it been granted it was the view and
the and the uh the trees
but this is my understanding is that
there this is open Countryside but it is
it is not in an area of special
landscape significance it's not in an
area of an outstanding natural beauty it
is
in common Parliament it's common a
garden agricultural land
um and and therefore it is not of of a
special protected uh status and and my
understanding of our position is that
that is not sufficient the loss of this
this particular piece of land is not
sufficient to outweigh our statutory
obligation under the self-built and
custom building act therefore I don't
think we have I don't think we have the
evidence to do other than to go along
with the recommendation to refuse
sorry to approve
Freudian slip is that again is that a
proposal to go ahead with the office of
recommendation yes thank you councilor
Perry please
thank you chair
this one hurts
Big Time particularly as someone who was
part of the neighborhood development
plan team
for must have been three years I guess
um so this one really hurts because I
think I agree with the ward member it is
totally in the wrong location
wellsborn has had more than its fill yes
there are views yes the footpaths
is is is is absolutely crucial
but I have to remind committee members
we are here to make very difficult
decisions on planning policy
and the problem I have with this
and I have to apologize to councilor
prior
because
I can't find a material planning reason
to refuse because I know this will go to
appeal if we refuse it
we are delaying I do not like it one
little bit
but I am sitting here and as I tell you
I was on that NDP team doing all the
questionnaires and surveys and analyzing
stuff even when I was on holiday
and I have every sympathy with the
objection from the parish council
because I totally agree with them but
the problem we have the self-built ACT
arrived after the call strategy and
after the NDP was adopted and therefore
we have legal requirements
because it will just be we will face
costs and therefore reluctantly very
reluctantly
because I'm not someone who abstains I
am someone who makes a difficult
decision
and therefore my difficult decision is
that we have no alternative in my view
but to Grant
can I just confirm it whether you are or
aren't second in councilor Harvey's
proposal
I will reluctantly second it thank you
very much Council Curtis next please
thank you and I just wonder if
the committee would consider the ward
members recommendation that we have a
site visit to assess the highways impact
whether that would make any difference
to our deliberations on this
you're welcome to make a proposal that
we defer and go on a site visit but I'd
like to understand exactly what your
reasoning for that is all right thank
you I'll think thank you cancer Crump
please
yeah um I fully understand
sentiments but unfortunately in the
report they phrase no objection
and it'd be very difficult to go against
the highways Authority
um no objection on that I fully
endorsement I'm the big believer in Road
Safety you know I'm really a strong
advocate of that but I think we've got
to be
mindful that they are the highways
Authority unless we've got significant
evidence to say they've made a a big
mistake and as Mr Brooks said that
section 278 agreements do hold
significant way to solve so that the
application will be able to go ahead
unless those section two submit
agreements hadn't been
um hadn't been fully signed and endorsed
by the county I think we're we're
slightly going down the wrong road or
wrong path there and that's an open on
this occasion goes because so um yeah I
I can fully understand your sentiment
and again
on this one I've been trying to find
ways around this because I don't like
the fact that that the parish and tank
councils go through the NDP process they
sweat Blood Sweat and Tears to get it
done and all of a sudden something's
imposed on them it says I'm sorry all
that hard work you've done is slightly
out of date and you've got to do this
um we've previously when we've had um
when we haven't had a approved core
strategy we've had to go on the basis of
sustainable development when we haven't
had the five-year house and none Supply
again the the unsustainable development
in favor of granted and it is very
difficult and I sort of liken that to
the five-year housing Online Supply and
the approved plan I don't like it
um it's interesting to hear that that
they call um
at the next door member to the ward
member
um supporting this and I can I could
tell councilor probably frustration in
the way she was having to deal with it
it was almost like through gritted teeth
um that yeah so I will be supporting
this I'm not particularly Keen but I
think our hands are tied on this the
longest in two case I knew quite
intimately because I used to live there
I knew the area well I'm grouping that
way so I can understand the difference
and how much weight was given on that
and how I I don't think he's quite as
comparable to Long Nation turn case that
that went to appeal and was was lost by
by the applicant so again I will be
reluctantly voter for this application
thank you chair
um
the officers do we know if actually
Warwick Highway was paid a site visit
I mean the reality is they have given a
no objection
um regardless of whether they've made a
site visit yeah I've dealt with highways
for some time and a lot of the times
they don't come out
I understand that
um the point I suppose I'm making is
that they're the professionals they're
the ones we have to rely on to
understand their Highway Network they
will make their assessments based on
their own process and policies the other
thing is
um
I agree with the ward member in the
parish member
um
we don't take enough notice of the
library development plan you know what
is the point if we don't even take
notice of it and if they're the wrong
housing type in the area then I can't
support this application thank you
okay thank you I would just say that we
do absolutely take notice of
neighborhood development plans
unfortunately in this instance there is
a national policy that does override
that which is a great shame
um because a great deal of work does go
into those ndps members do we have
anything else we want to say during
debates if not we have a proposal to
grant that has been seconded so we will
move to a vote could I have a show of
hands for those in favor of granting in
line with the office recommendation
please
five and those against
three committee therefore resolves to
Grant application
2200182 o u t
thank you very much right let's move on
to our final application of the evening
which is application reference
2203530 ful The Old Mill House in
Kyneton and our presenting officer will
be Malvina iziac in just a moment
okay so one Malvina it has all of her
presentation up and ready to go and
she's ready to go the floor there's over
to you thank you good evening
um
so uh
the application site is located within
the build up area boundary of counten as
indicated by the black dot on the plan
shown
the next slide shows the application
side
uh it is a corner plot surrounded by
dwellings of varied types and sizes to
the north there is an area of open Green
Space
as you can hear as you can see the
this is the existing side one
the site has the existing vehicular
access from milk Russian to the West
just uh
and The Pedestrian access of Mill Lane
from the north
the existing dwelling is located in the
Southeast corner of the site
and overgrown vegetation denotes the
existing site boundary with milk
Russians and Mill Lane
what is being proposed planning
permission is sought to demolish the
existing dwelling and erect three number
of four bed detached dwellings and
Associated development including two new
accesses
of Mill Lane
with the existing axis of milk Crescent
being closed
this slide shows the proposed site plan
including the section of the existing
hedge to be retained to the west and new
planting along the northern northern
boundary
the next slide shows the proposed
dwellings and the context
of the surrounding build form
this slide shows the existing elevations
and on this slide you can see front
elevations of the proposed dwellings
number one two and three including side
elevations
this is the proposed
ground and first floor plans
they're very similar to
all three proposed dwellings
on this slide you can see a scaled
Street Scene elevations
so on the top
this is along Mill Lane so you can see
the front
and at the bottom this is from the side
are seen from Mill Crescent
you can note on this plan that the reach
of twin Cottage
is that noticeably lower than The Ridges
of the proposed dwellings
this Photograph shows the existing
dwelling that's the front elevation
facing west
this photograph is taken from the
junction of male Crescent with male Lane
and shows the site looking towards the
southeast Direction
so this is the site
and you can see the dwelling probably
you can't see but the dwelling is
located there
this photograph is taken within Mill
Lane
the site is
denoted by the Hedge there and this is
the application dwelling
there is a pedestrian link adjacent to
the gate of number one rose Cradock just
there
so this is the existing vehicular access
of mail Crescent you can see the
application dwelling in the background
and twin Cottage to the side
this photo shows
the existing vehicular access
to the site and twin Cottage looking
southwards
and this image shows the view within
middle creation looking towards the
north Direction you can see twin Cottage
there
this is the existing vehicular access to
the site
this is the site and
further to the north there is the open
Green Space
as you can see there
chairman the balance recommendation is
to approve the application for planning
permissions subject to the conditions as
detailed within the committee report
thank you
mavina thank you very much indeed let's
call our first speaker on this item who
is cancer David Gosling of Kyneton
Parish Council good evening councilor
Gosling
and welcome
you've got a good idea of what's going
to happen now so you'll have three
minutes I'll give you 30 second warning
whenever you're sat comfortable and
ready to go button on the right and the
floor is yours
all right good evening
um in the officer's report there's
confirmation that the number of new
homes constructed and or committed
within the kite within the kind and
built up area boundary March last year
was 272 and that's 40 percent more than
the minimum numbers that the plan labor
plan supported
um so whilst the principle of
development may be in line with course
strategy 16 for the district it's
arguably now well out of step with the
neighborhood plan which carries more
weight than the core strategy
and there are other policy related
reasons to refuse this application
the street scene proposed which you've
got a glimpse of indicates that there
will be a low 0.6 meter hedge
conditioned as part of the development
what that artist's drawing did not show
you is the nine cars in the car park
between the Hedge and the front of the
three dwellings and I'd like to suggest
that the proposal would therefore be
harmful to the character and local
distinctiveness of the street scene and
therefore not in accord with policies
cs9 cs20 or of the neighborhood plan
policies H4 D1 or D2
um if you um can look at that scale
drawing up there in the pre-application
device highways made a requirement
um if I can find it
um
that
there needs to be a minimum spacing of
15 meters required between the channel
line of the major arm of the junction
and the nearest side of a vehicular axis
on the minor arm of the Junction now I'm
not quite sure what that actually means
um but if we've interpreted it correctly
then that distance shown by the um by
the red line is only 13.4 meters so if
nothing else I'd like you to consider
extending this application back to
highways and asking them to explain why
they're not following through on their
own Highway design guide
um turning back again to the
neighborhood plan which carries material
weight there is no evidence to support
the need for three four bedroomed homes
in the village whereas there is evidence
from a recent housing needs survey
conducted within the last 12 months of
Need for smaller dwellings and in
particular Bungalows I suggest that with
all the valid reasons that we have for
objecting to this site they could be
overcome by developing with more
suitable dwellings
looking then to another reason there is
no way that you could say other than
harm is outweighing the benefits because
there are no benefits in planning terms
to these three four bedroom houses being
built there 30 seconds
um if on the um sad outcome that you
decide to Grant planning permission then
can I also point out that the rear
Gardens are very short from front to
back they're very wide so they seem to
satisfy the requirements for square
footage square meterage but because they
are very short from front to back
um we would ask you to consider removing
the permitted development rights which
would allow an extension to be built on
the back of those houses or any of them
thank you very much
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions for our Parish
Council
Council Curtis
thank you
um thank you very much so you 've sort
of alluded about that it is not
necessarily development on this site for
say that the parish council objects to
that these particular or this particular
proposal doesn't meet the local housing
need
so if if another plan were to come
forward proposal to come work to come
forward with say three two bedroom
Bungalows Parish Council may not
maintain its objection
of course I can't speak for the parish
council without it going back to a
council meeting
um
the the community is bothered about the
number of additional housing that we are
still being subjected to given the
numbers that we have already delivered
while in excess of those that were
expected
um but we would look at a different
application on that site in the same way
there are issues that are associated
with cars and car parking
um those cars have to reverse in to
those spaces
um any of you sitting here will probably
wonder how you're going to juggle those
cars so there's displaced car parking so
all those things need to be taken into
the balance
okay thank you any other questions I
have one you mentioned the highways and
15 meters but I missed the next bit I
wasn't quick enough to write it down
could you read it to me again please
would you would you like the wording
that was taken from the pre-app advised
by highways
um what I'm looking for is you said um
the minimum distance from a junction
should be 15 meters and I think you said
from the near side of point of exit or
something to that effect yeah could you
read that bit again for me please it's
15 meters between the channel line of
the major arm of the junction which we
take to be Mill Crescent
and the nearest side of a vehicular
access on the minor arm of the junction
and
we we think that the two blue lines on
that top right hand corner top left hand
corner would be whatever that um wording
is from the highways department and that
measurement is not 15 meters it's 13
point
four
okay thank you very much I will clarify
that with officers my understanding is
it's 2.4 meters out from the center
point of the access but we will clarify
that later on
if there are no other questions for our
uh Ward number Parish Council forgive me
uh then thank you very much for your
time contribution and your patience
okay let's move to our next speaker who
is Mr James May
good evening and welcome again you've
probably got a good idea of how things
are going to go you will have three
minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning when you'll come from ready to
go the floor is yours thank you good
evening I am the I live at Twin Cottage
the nearest neighbor of Old Mill House I
the parish council and the local
community all object this proposal for
what the clear and valid reasons the
strength of objection to proposal is
highlighted by the 27 objections
received and the attendance of its
closest Neighbors at this meeting given
the type I will only focus on a few key
points before I do let's remember that
we are all here ultimately to consider
the national planning policy framework
which summarize the objective of
sustainable development as meeting the
needs of the presence whilst
compromising not without compromising
ability of future generations to meet
their own needs firstly The Proposal is
for three large detached four bedroom
homes built on Garden land on a site
which is playing up large enough for the
proposal in particular the spd's
guidelines are that Gardens be a minimum
of 10.5 meters in length moreover that
the gardens may need to be large of
reasons of privacy particularly for
enjoying dwellings and private Gardens
both plot 2 and 3 fail this two and a
half meter Criterion poorly considering
the needs of future occupants this point
is not adequately considered in the
planning office committee report
secondly the commit the planning officer
incorrectly states that with no windows
facing twin Cottage and the proposed
buildings this is not correct the south
facing bedroom of plot 1 and a
north-facing bedroom of twin Cottage
will directly face each other and are
only 16 meters apart and this is
contrary to SPD F4 which states there
should be 21 meters between facing
habitable room windows
now the SPD states that where windows
are looking towards neighbors Gardens
there should be a minimum of 10 meters
away unless the wind is obscured this is
not the case plots two and three will be
closer than this and directly
overlooking plot one will also be
overlooking the planet office deposits
that our garden is generous and that
private areas near the house will not be
affected the planning officer does not
appreciate that our patio the most
private area where we relax and
entertain in is directly overlooked by
plots 2 and 3 and which are too close
let's be clear if this proposal is built
it means that the entire and most
private areas of our garden will be
overlooked by six bedroom windows
finally the current character of the
area will be permanently damaged by this
proposal which seeks to demolish a
historic building that positively
contributes to the heritage of the
village irrespective of its listing it
results in a net loss of vegetation
biodiversity and habitat to be replaced
by pavement and car parking 30 seconds
properties proposed will utterly
dominate the street scene standing over
their neighbors by up to two meters I
hope it is clear to committee members
that this proposal should be refused it
clearly does not meet the current needs
of the community or those of the future
occupiers we all Aspire and deserve a
better proposal than this
which is entirely feasible thank you for
your time
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions for Mr May
no in that case Mr May thank you very
much for your time contribution to your
patience this evening
all right let's go to our final speakers
of the evening who are our agents Jane
Cashmore and our applicant Barnaby
Briggs
um I Believe Miss Cashmore you'll be
doing all the Talking Mr Briggs here for
questions is that correct marvelous in
that case whenever you're sat come from
ready to go you will have six minutes
um
the floor is yours thank you good
evening
we would first like to thank the
planning officer for her hard work on
the application and comprehensive report
I'd like to focus my time on the key
objections raised by Third parties the
parish council and councilor Mills
with regards to highways matters the
application follows an initial
pre-application inquiry with
Warwickshire County Council highways
the plans were drawn up in conjunction
with highways Consultants taking into
account that pre-application feedback
a transport appraisal accompanies this
application including an independent
road safety audit this has all been
reviewed by Warwickshire County Council
highways who raised no objection to the
development subject to conditions
each dwelling is provided with three
off-road car parking spaces meeting the
council's requirements for a
four-bedroomed house and the submitted
statement by David Tucker Associates
includes tracking for those parking
spaces
a shed is proposed in each Garden for
cycle storage as you know kindton is a
main Rural Center and the site is well
within the built-up area boundary
providing easy access on foot to many
amenities
a key benefit of the development is the
proposed new footway along the site
Frontage with drop curb Crossing Point
connecting to the footway on Mill
Crescent this is one of several wider
public benefits arising from the
development
comments have been made about responding
to local character and over development
if you refer to the plan which I think
is at page 81 of your agenda papers
you'll see the reality is that the
pattern of development and character of
properties in the area is mixed there's
a variety of building lines variety of
Ages of property and various scales of
dwelling
some properties are set in staggered
building lines others straight other
properties are set back with no Road
Frontage
properties are also detached or
terrorists and there's a variety of
heights of properties in the area mostly
two-story but some are also 2.5 story
with the exception of the existing house
other properties surrounding the
adjacent public open space front onto it
the application proposal rectifies this
by the three proposed houses positively
fronting onto the open space
proposed houses have common design
themes but subtle variety for interest
in terms of materials porch design and
window design
plot one also provides an active side
elevation to Mill Crescent
part of the existing hedrow onto Mill
Crescent is shown to be retained and
it's visibly Apparent from the Block
plan submitted that this density and
proposal is not out of keeping with the
variety of development in the locality
we've also altered materials at the
request of the planning officer
you've heard a number of comments this
evening and within the report from third
parties about the local housing needs
survey and preferred provision of
Bungalows for clarity The Proposal is
for open market dwellings unrestricted
by legal agreement this is fully
acceptable in principle in both the core
strategy and neighborhood plan
there's no policy requirement for this
development to be local needs dwelling
in terms of housing mix neighborhood
plan policy H5 refers to housing mix
and this relates to developments of 10
or more dwellings
the applicant is also spoken with a
local estate agent who says there is a
demand for the type of dwelling proposed
with regards the demolition of the
existing dwelling the property is not
within the conservation area not listed
not identified in any specific Heritage
database such as a local list or the
historic environment record additionally
it's in poor condition the applicant who
has first-hand knowledge of the property
for many years can elaborate on this if
you wish
archeology Warwickshire have visited the
site and been inside the property its
value is low and local at best
they recommend historic building
recording via VIA planning condition
enabling preservation by record and the
applicant has no objection to this this
condition is proposed in the
recommendation
in terms of ecology the application is
submitted with a preliminary ecological
appraisal and County ecology raised no
objection subject conditions
neighboring Manatee is covered in detail
in the report and update sheet and I'd
refer you to the detailed officer
assessment which concludes impacts are
acceptable
we've heard from the neighbor this
evening
the supplementary planning document
provides guidelines
with regards to Windows facing towards
Gardens the wording within the
supplementary planning
document just refer to
talks about Windows looking towards
neighbors gardens near to their house
and in terms of amenity space as set out
in the officer report what is provided
is adequate
so in summary the proposed development
lies in the sustainable Village of
Kyneton would deliver public benefits
and has been carefully designed with
input from various Consultants I hope
you're able to support your officer
recommendation to Grant and thank you
for listening
thank you very much indeed well within
your time members do we have any
questions for either our applicant or
the agent
Council Curtis thank you thank you very
much um you mentioned earlier on the
foot I think you said the one of the
footwears is going to be enhanced and
you said that was one of several wider
public benefits and then you just
concluded by saying it would deliver
public benefits could you give an
outline of what those additional public
benefits would be please certainly yes
so um in my view that the public
benefits from this are the
um the proposed dwellings front on to
the open space so creating surveillance
of it which is in keeping the character
of the area so overlooking of the open
space
um there's some ecological enhancements
enclosed included in the proposal which
had to be secured by condition there is
sustainability and renewable benefits in
the proposed dwelling solar panels there
Source heat pumps Etc
um the footway which you've mentioned
and the net gain in dwellings of
family-sized
any other questions members
no in that case both of you thank you
very much for your time contribution
this evening
the war member has as you know has given
his apologies he's sadly not available
to come tonight he has asked me to
mention that he's his comments in the
application in the uh offices report uh
he maintains those they're on page 70
for anyone that wants to read them I'm
sure you already have so let's move to
points for clarification with our
officers councilor Harvey first please
particular
objections which I took note of amongst
a number he made one related to size of
gardens one related to Windows facing
and uh each other and thirdly the
question of overlooking I wonder if the
case officer could say something about
each of those three items to to convince
me that what is proposed is within
policy thank you
and of course so um in terms of the size
of the proposed Gardens
um the relevant part of the SPD I think
it was part L
um
suggests the
the indicative widths and depths of the
gardens but the main
um Criterion is the size of the garden
so
um in my opinion
um
there there is a
requirement
of the minimum area but they're due to
the different circumstances there is no
requirement to have a garden of this
particular minimum with or death I think
in my opinion
this was included in the relevant part
of the SPD to prevent for example one
meter
um
with of a garden
so basically part L requires the minimum
area and
the
the council to satisfy themselves that
this area is usable and even though
some of these proposed Gardens do not
meet the width or depths they have
sufficient area and they they are usable
they would be usable and on that basis I
did not raise objection to to the shapes
of the gardens
um and the next question was
um
was it about the windows
Windows facing each other
oh yes
um
councilor Harvey I hope I've interpreted
your question correctly I thought it
related to the roof light
photograph that we showed earlier that's
the the window that's facing the the
other point was overlooking wasn't it I
have I misunderstood you what did you
mean by Windows facing if if it's
different to overlooking what is it
Vista May quoted figures of 16 meters
and Twitter as opposed to 21 meters
ah
okay so that's that's the answer in
there isn't it uh yes so
um
the relationship between plot Number One
and
um
twin Cottage is signed to rear and
Part F requires the separation to be
minimum 13 meters which is achieved and
on that basis I did not raise objection
to this relationship
um in terms of potential overlooking of
the
proposed Garden from that window
Part F requires that
the window
must be obscure glazed unless there is a
separation distance of 10 meters
to this most private area which would
again be achieved and also looking at
the photo
you can see that the view is partially
obscured by the existing dwelling
and
so
my understanding is that the roof light
is located there
and the Outlook would
um not affect this area of patio
um
adversely
I think I can if I interpret what you've
said on on three ground you're you're
saying that you're satisfied that in
your opinion or explicitly the points
are within policy
yes correct
um
in terms of the comments I understand
that you wanted to clarify the impacts
the over the potential overlooking
impacts from the dwellings on the patio
area as well is this what you
wanted to clarify so um the planning
guide the guidelines contained in part f
um seek to protect the most private
amenity immediately to the rear of
dwellings
so even though it is acknowledged in my
report that there would be overlooking
impacts on the existing patio area in
the middle of the garden
um
due to the size of the neighboring
garden and the fact that the most
private area to the immediately to the
rear of the house would not be affected
by the development
uh on balance I accepted that the
impacts
would be there but they are within the
guidelines
a plan that we looked at earlier that
shows the most private area Garden of to
Twin house
um
take your time
um so on this aerial view you can see
um The Patio area that I put the
boundary uh with the application site so
this patio area
um would be affected by some overlooking
however you can see that there there is
ample space immediately to the rear of
the house
that could be used as a seating area and
this area would not be affected by any
overlooking
so just to clarify that chairman uh
there may be some loss that there will
be some loss of privacy to that first
patio area that um that Malvina uh
flagged up there will be some loss of
privacy to that this is an urban
location it's in the middle of a village
it's an area where Gardens are
overlooked by adjoining properties
and it's not in any way unusual or
unreasonable for parts of gardens to be
overlooked but they will in addition be
a totally private area remaining so
officers consider there is there is no
uh instance where the level of privacy
is becomes unacceptable
yeah
thank you very much cancer Eden please
thank you chair
um the agent referred to
um there may be a a diagram with
tracking for the car parking do you
happen to have that to hand if you don't
that's fine
um
I think
continue working
this is a document of 43 Pages it might
take me a minute or two to find it
councilor Edna are you specifically
looking for tracking or are you looking
to understand the visibility splay
particularly in relation to the parish
council comment about 15 meters from the
channel line of the major arm of the
junction near side of the vehicle access
and arm of the junction
uh the tracking not the visibility not
what I said you didn't steal my question
good we've got this
that is the plan councilor Eden uh I
hope you can see do you want me to zoom
in on it
um it's showing
I need to be careful here I've never
seen this plan before in my life
so
I'd better not pretend I know more than
I do it's clearly showing the tracking
of how Vehicles enter and leave
uh the first entrance to the first two
plots plots one and two beyond that I
think it's wise if I don't say any more
because I don't know enough about it
does it answer your question do you want
me to zoom in on any part of it
fine thank you
I'll hand control back to Malvina
thank you for that while we're on that
one I've got Captain sir Curtis to come
in a second while we're on that and
talking about highways um we did hear
from the parish council about the uh
visibility space and distance from the
um entry and uh or the access to the
site versus the uh Junction uh adjacent
to it
the description that was given was along
the lines of and forgive me for not
getting this absolutely right 15 meters
from the channel line of the major
Junction arm of the junction to the near
side of the vehicular access of the arm
of the junction I don't understand that
my understanding from experience on this
committee and through planning
applications is that the measurement is
taken from the center point of the
access
2.4 meters out I believe and then from
there is that correct and if that is
correct is it 15 meters to the junction
if that's not correct can you help me
understand what I need to understand
thank you chairman um
yes it would normally be from the center
line of the of the junction uh it came
as a little bit of a surprise to me when
Mr May said as he did from the the near
side of the junction
um but I don't question what he said I'm
sure it was absolutely correct
uh I've checked the measurement that
that Mr May gave you which was 13.4
meters I believe
yes I do apologize I was going to
correct him in a minute I've checked the
measurement that Mr Gosling councilor
Gosling gave you which I think was 13.4
meters and that's the figure I have come
up with so we're certainly in agreement
with councilor Gosling but it is 13.4
meters uh as far as I can tell that is
the dimension that Mr Gosling counselor
Gosling described who Morty wrote
um what I would say is that we uh we
might ask for all manner of things we
might give guidance on all manner of
things applicants don't always deliver
what we ask for they deliver something
Less in this instance I remember
specifically the councilor Gosling asked
why didn't this development follow the
guidance well the critical thing is it's
guidance
it's not written in tablets of stone the
highway authority of clearly considered
it and concluded that at 13.4 it is near
enough to 15 and they have raised no
objection
that's the only answer we can give you
tonight Jim
okay Council Curtis
sorry thank you
um well we knew you would we were just
referring back to I think it was
counselor Harvey who raised the issue of
garden with depth size
um You and I
think I've got this correct please tell
me if I haven't
um you said that the policy dictates the
area of the garden but there are
indications
I think that was the word you used that
yeah that gives some indication of
desirable depth or length of the gardens
could you say could you tell us what
those indications are in terms of the
length or depth of gardens
oh one moment I will find a relevant
see well Melvina does that can I just
remind counselors of the word guidance
and the words planning judgment that
I've used before always relevant in
these instances whatever the numbers say
guidance and judgment must be used
okay so I found the relevant
part of the of part l so in terms of
residential rear or side Gardens
um as a general guideline a rear Garden
um
length of
10.5 meters and a width of 5 meters
should would provide a reasonably
functional area of private private
outdoor space
however for other site-specific and
design reasons Gardens may need to be
larger
and then
this table provides indicative minimum
garden areas by house type and you can
see that for four bedroom houses the
minimum is 62 square meters of the of
the area and the smallest Garden exceeds
100 square meters so this is well above
what the policy normally requires for
this type of dwelling
thank you okay members do we have any
other points that need clarifying before
we move to debate
no in that case let's move to debate who
would like to kick us off
don't all jump at once
am I gonna have to do this is Council
Harvey doing it
I can understand
the neighbors
objections when you've not been used to
having three properties in in your next
door plot and somebody comes along with
this sort of a suggestion
so I understand that
um I think I've I think we have tested
out the minimum requirements uh in in a
number of dimensions in relation to this
application and found that the
application seems to be within policy
and therefore the officer having made a
recommendation based upon considering
all the facts and all the policies
it's open to us to find a policy reason
to object
and
in the circumstances uh the question for
instance of 40 over development over the
the cs-16 target sort of figure is Not
Unusual in this in this District we all
know of uh wards that have got parishes
that have got more than 100 percent
um so we have to find planning reasons
to go against the officer's
recommendation if we can find them and I
haven't heard a convincing planning
reason this evening I've heard grants
for objection I've got I've heard
grounds for concern but I haven't heard
a convincing planning reason and
therefore I will support the grant
recommendation
is that a proposal to Grant yes thank
you very much anyone else Council Curtis
please I
struggling a little bit with this one um
and I'm just looking at the size of some
of these Gardens and now
um Halloween has given us this it is I
think it was guidance
of 10 and a half meters for Back Garden
the length maximum length of plot three
is 8.2 going down to six meters and I I
listen carefully to planning managers
Dale's comments that guidance and
judgment must be used
um and yes the committee does need to
use its guidance and judgment very
carefully
just chucking that into the mixture
that's right thank
you thank you thank you chair
um I'll be honest I'm struggling more
with the frontages
and the and the tracking parking I just
think
the the plot design overall is
um
poor
in my opinion
um I think it could be laid out
differently and and make that work a bit
better but that is my opinion
um I am equally those struggling to find
anything to go against with as much as
I'd like to so that is my only comment
that's not a second thing of counselor
Harvey's proposal no I'm I'm not in
favor at the moment understood
anyone else Council for me
thank you chair
um I'm also uncomfortable with this
um application I particularly plot three
in the size of the back garden and I
have a lot of sympathy with Mr May and
the overlooking of his garden but as
counselor Harvey says I I'm struggling
to find a reason to go against the
officer planning reason to go against
the officer at the moment
Concentra seraphin yeah
um
looking at it it looks over developed on
this plot
the gardens aren't really big enough and
there's definitely no front garden and
it looks like a dodgium fair dude
the design of of the whole Frontage is
not quite right which is probably the
houses are too big for the plot so you
can't much maneuver around it
but you know it's struggling against
what we can as a planning reason against
it you know I don't like it
okay
um
I'll throw my thoughts I I don't
disagree with most of you that this is
not a
this is not what I would have designed
if it were me doing the design but the
reality is this is what's in front of us
so we have to make a decision based on
what's in front of us
um we've had no statutory Consulting
come back with an objection
I do have concern about the access and
its proximity to the junction
we have heard that highways do not have
an objection to it
that is the only thing that I feel
comfortable putting our hat to if we're
inclined to go against the officer's
recommendation
and I don't think it's very strong
um
I have absolute sympathy with Mr May uh
but as we've heard
the design the size of the gardens uh
the windows and their views and
overlooking is within our policy
um so on that basis thank you
on that basis I am going to Second
councilor Harvey's recommendation sorry
Council Harvey's proposal to Grant in
line with the office of recommendation
I'm going to give you one last chance to
come forward with any other comment or
points of debate before we move to a
vote
no one wants to do that
we heard earlier on and forgive me but I
can't remember who said it about
removing PD rights I think it was
probably councilor Gosling
um on plot three
councilor Harvey given you made the
proposal are you uh comfortable
including the removal of PD rights
either for all or just one of those
properties
foreign
I'd be content to see PD rights removed
from all three
thank you very much on the basis that uh
of the of their proximity to the the
neighboring dwellings I presume
um I'm happy for that to go in as the
second day so I think we have concluded
the debate as best we can could I please
have a show of the hands for those in
favor of granting application 2203530
three and those against
three
the last application of the last
planning committee of the municipal year
thanks
unfortunately that does
return to me for the casting vote
um I've set out my position already and
I will maintain my position and
therefore committee resolves to Grant
application
2203530 ful as the Old Mill House in
Clinton
um do we have any urgent business please
Kira no in that case
um it leaves me to thank all of our
speakers and members of the public for
their contributions this year and
tonight sorry and over the last four
years
um to members some of you are seeking
re-election some of you are not
um uh best of luck to those that are I
hope to see around this table again soon
uh for those that are not thank you for
your contribution over the last four
years uh and Beyond if if indeed you've
been here longer than that
um but in particular and it would be
interesting not to thank all of the
officers that have been involved
throughout the last uh four years in
this planning committee
um whether they be planning officers
solicitor uh our committee Services
Representatives even highways and other
contributors without them we wouldn't be
able to function so a huge thanks to you
all um
oh
and we will see you hopefully see you
all in the next Council year thank you
very much sure can I just I would just
like to thank you for I think you've
shared some very difficult meetings
extremely well we haven't always agreed
but I think your your guidance as chair
has been extremely good and I would like
to thank you for that yeah
that's very kind thank you very much